COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we help some fresh developers
find their ideal VM
configuration.
Will we fix things before
the performance goes stale?
Stay tuned to find out.
Enfuego coin is a hot new
cryptocurrency trading startup
that has just taken
the plunge into using
custom images for their VMs.
Sadly, though, after
months of trying,
they couldn't get the
right machine type--
too high, too low, costs
all over the place.
But they are not alone.
Without the right
level of analysis,
profiling, and
benchmarking, it's
really difficult to
figure out if you're
paying too much for
your configuration
or are throttling your
performance unknowingly.
As it turns out, hitting the
sweet spot is really hard
and involves doing
something like this.
Firstly, discuss what your
expected performance benchmarks
are for various systems from
the perspective of the clients
and the other key dependencies,
i.e., the systems that
will be using it.
Number two, create a
benchmark and testing suite
to test I/O performance,
CPU utilization, and memory
performance for your VM.
Then, number three, start
with a small machine,
benchmark it, and test the
results against those desired
outcomes.
And if things
aren't fast enough,
try the next largest machine.
And then finally, continue
this entire process
until you've found
the sweet spot.
Now listen, you've
got better things
to do than worry about
this problem, which
is why Google
Compute Engine does
all the heavy lifting for you.
In fact, it will just
tell you directly
if you could be saving
money on your VM page
and what configuration
it suggests using.
So how does GCE come up
with these recommendations?
Compute Engine monitors the
CPU and memory utilization
of running virtual machines
and makes recommendations
using the last eight days of
data on standard and custom
machine types.
There's a lot of magic
going on here that we don't
have time to cover, though.
So to learn more about how
to use the recommendations,
and how Stackdriver can help
you get even better estimates,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas
content because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]